welcome back everyone a sweet spectacle
is making its debut this morning on the
las vegas strip
it's a sugar palace made from all sorts
of treats and it's right in the lobby
of the aria resort and joining us this
morning is chef
andrea madrid she is the assistant
pastry chef at the aria
good morning to you chef that is
stunning
behind you tell us all about it
thank you good morning here at aria we
have for you our winter wonderland sugar
palace that we have created
we are encouraging everybody to very
safely visit us
and come check it out we will have our
socially distanced lines and sanitizer
stations as well for everybody to enjoy
um we created the sugar palace the
entire thing is almost
uh four thousand pounds of sugar wow we
created it with
over a thousand pressed sugar bricks we
have over 500 roof tiles
and we're going to have a lot of
different uh really cute retail items as
well as well some beverages
for everybody to enjoy that is stunning
so chef it's
15 feet tall how do you begin to build
that
what keeps it together
well it was actually i want to say it
was actually a very big collaboration
with a few of the other departments
here at aria so we had a team that also
kind of built the structure for us
and our pastry team really just um put
it together
um what you see here that's incredible
so is it icing that keeps it all
together
yes we have it completely decorated with
royal icing in between
every brick every tile that you see it
is royal icing as well as decorated
around some of the other areas of the
house
that is stunning so when the holidays
are over what do you do with it
how do you take it apart
it will be up until a little after new
year's but we do
unfortunately have to just take it down
oh
how sad it is stunning you know i wanted
to ask you too
we hear that you were on the netflix
show sugar high not only were you on it
but you won the show
so if you recognize chef that might be
why tell us about that
it was a very fun very great experience
it was
it was nothing like we've ever done
before here at arya so it was
you know it was an honor just to be even
chosen for something like that um
and you know the fact that we won was
just kind of very
overwhelming very exciting you know we
didn't expect it but i think that also
just goes to show the kind of team we
have here at aria and the things we're
capable of ah well we all know what
you're capable of we are
lucky enough to get to see it so chef
thank you so much for being with us
i can't wait to see the sugar palace
safely behind you and you have a great
thanksgiving thanks for your time